thank you for the introduction hi
everyone I am Aaron sidford I am one of
the many organizers of this current
program happening on data structures and
optimization for algorith design
something like that um so I'm
unfortunate to be organizing the program
along with Alina na Monica henser yint
Lee and galani and I guess in the three
minutes I have I thought I had five
minutes just GNA give you a very brief
sense of what this program is on data
structures and optimization for fast
algorithms so there's a number of
different things that's motiv ating this
program happening this quarter um one of
the key motivations underneath this
program happening is a number of
advances that have happened in the last
few years in algorithm design so for a
wide range of kind of our fundamental
foundational algorithmic and
optimization problems like convex
programming linear system solving
analyzing random walks and marov chains
Computing flows and graphs optimizing
mcra decision processes for this broad
range of some of our foundational
algorithmic and optimization tasks
there's been breakthrough after
breakthrough in many cases improving run
times that haven't seen improvements for
decades and in some cases for the first
time achieving some of these holy grail
results of provably solving these
problems in nearly linear or almost
linear time and what's I think
particularly exciting about these
results Beyond just you know they've
been the pursuit of algorithm design for
uh decades is the wide range of tools
and techniques that have underline these
advances so these tools and many of
these results they use different
optimization methods like gradient
descent interior Point methods and
multiplicative weights they use a
variety of data structures to then
Implement these optimization methods
efficiently different sorts of ways of
maintaining decompositions of large
graphs different ways of processing
matrices to get information out of them
efficiently and then in enabling those
data structures they also use a variety
of sketching techniques maybe some
techniques we think of for processing
very large data sets or working in low
memory and in low space um and there's a
number of Rich interesting way these
tools and techniques have been combined
so some of of these optimization some of
these results they work by using the
optimization method to reduce the
optimization problem to a data structure
problem that is then solved using
sketching techniques some of these Works
use the optimization methods that solve
these problems dynamizing the
optimization method or using the
optimization Theory to reduce Dynamic
problems to solving sequence of static
optimization problems and given all
these rich connections and has been
discussed the point one of the many
roles of the program in tying together
researchers from a variety of areas the
goal of the program is we have
researchers and experts in all these
different areas of data structures
optimization sketching and we're
bringing them together towards getting
faster algorithms um the goal is to find
new connections between these areas get
new advancements more efficient
algorithms um hopefully open the door to
more areas of research and push all the
amazing research that's already
happening um we've already had two
workshops uh three workshops complete we
have one last one scheduled if you're
interested in the program you can check
out the videos from the workshops that
have already happened and I think I'm
out of time so thank
you